uh there's something interesting going
on within the evangelical christian
movement
which is that to uh to some degree
prominent evangelical christians have
started to
sort of turn on donald trump or at least
acknowledge that it's it's time to go
buddy
90 year old extremist evangelical
televangelist leader pat robertson of
700 club fame
accurately assesses the cult of
personality around donald trump
and says it's time to move on you really
have to see this to believe it
and there's an interesting irony here
which i'm going to discuss after
discuss with you after we look at this
first clip i think it's all over
i think the electoral college has spoken
i think the
the biden corruption
has not totally been brought to
fruition but it doesn't seem to be
affecting the electoral college
and i don't think the supreme court is
going to move in to do anything
and i think we're going to see a
president biden
and i also think we'll be seeing a
president
campbell harris not too long after the
inauguration of president
biden with all his talent
and the ability of to raise money and
grow large crowds
the president still lives in an
alternate reality he really does
people say well he lies about this than
the other but no he
isn't lying to him that's the truth he
had the biggest crowd on inauguration
he had he had more people than ever he
was the most popular
of people up he saved nbc but with the
apprentice you go down the line of
things that
really aren't true and you know people
kept pointing to them but because
they loved him so much and he was so
strong for the evangelicals the
evangelists were with him all the way
but there was something about him that
was good
that god placed him in that office for
the time he's done a marvelous job for
the economy
but at the same time he is very erratic
and he
he's fired people he's fought people and
he's insulted people and keeps going
down the line
so it's it's a mixed bag and i think
it would be well to say you've had your
day
and it's time to move on what i love
about this
is that the same cult of personality
that pat robertson identifies as
surrounding donald trump
the same narcissism that pat robertson
identifies trump is suffering from
it's identical to both the followers
of evangelical cult leader types like
pat robertson and of the fall of the
leaders themselves
we wonder you know does trump believe
he's a liar or does he know he's lying
the cultish answer would be you know
eventually cult leaders become so
deluded
that what may start as things they know
to be lies
they end up kind of believing their own
lies or or at least
if they know they're lying they believe
they're lying for the right reason
because the means justify the ends or
they're telling some bigger truth if
they don't focus on the minutia
these are really common uh thought kind
of paradigms or mental models i think is
the right term
for cultish leaders of all kinds and
when pat robertson says trump believes
the lies
i suspect that the same applies to many
evangelical cultists like pat robertson
and others we've covered
they believe that the world is better
off when people donate to them
so that they can buy a private jet
because the private jet better allows
them to go and spread the gospel or
whatever it is that that they claim to
do
they get to a point where they have to
mostly believe their own lies in order
to continue living
uh a semi-coherently on just like a
day-to-day practical level
but pat robertson is mostly accurate in
his analysis of critique
and critique of trump it's just that
most of the analysis would apply as
accurately
to himself and to other evangelical
televangelist types like pat robertson
it's actually incredible though that pat
robertson
would accuse others of being in an
alternate reality
because pat robertson is a guy who has
said that the following
list of things can be demonic okay the
pat robertson says trump's in a fantasy
world pat robertson has said
second-hand sweaters can have demons
attached
ouija boards can be demonic yoga
is demonic harry potter feng shui
karate horoscopes the twilight series
actually you know what the twilight
series could be demonic but other than
that this list is crazy
paintings of buddha tv shows about
ghosts
halloween just writ large
psychics young girls who do levitation
during sleepovers and sometimes even
even adopted children from other
countries can be demonic
according to pat robertson and pat
robertson says
trump's living in an alternate reality
what a world we live in isn't it now one
other funny thing
i didn't know until yesterday that pat
robertson's son
is part of the grift gordon robertson
this is a new i
i guess this is maybe the the sort of
like televangelist heir to pat robertson
a gordon robertson who is pat
robertson's son
is also involved with the 700 club and
he also seems to have turned on donald
trump here's gordon robertson a few
weeks ago saying
he doesn't think the trump legal team is
is making any sense with what they're
doing
got to ask you if they're not going to
go forward with proof in these press
conferences
shouldn't they just shut down the press
conferences why why why have them i
i'm looking at this it's a complete
disaster for trump
and and why is he even doing it they
have had other press conferences
there's the famous four seasons total
landscaping
uh it just doesn't seem it doesn't seem
to be helping
whenever they get in front of the
cameras it just doesn't seem to be
helping
again the the question is always let's
see the evidence but
without people sort of buying in that
there's
evidence of widespread fraud if you
don't have that
and you have state legislatures coming
in and saying we're going to invalidate
the
vote totals and vote our own slate of
electors
in so that our team gets to win
aren't aren't you really playing with
fire i mean at that point in time
does anyone trust our democracy anymore
i mean
all the allegations that uh we're
looking at
um dictatorship that we're looking at
overthrowing democracy all of those
allegations come to the fore
and i would predict you'd see rioting in
the streets
how insane is that pat robertson and
gordon robertson
both saying trump's wacky while they are
completely wacky
fascinating to watch and i i my
instinct is that this
seeming realignment um is going to
disappear very quickly and everything
will go back to where it was much like i
said
um that republicans are going to sort of
forget about trump once trump disappears
and
who what trump i don't know we we're
here about we're here to lower the dead
and prevent socialism or whatever
i assume that the evangelical
televangelist types
that have started to see a little bit of
reason um
are going to go right back to the same
stuff joe biden's very demonic and and
so on
uh very quickly that that's my
prediction remains to be seen whether it
happens